il
[Musique]
le japon et le monde entier n'en vient
pote voir ces images on est encore sous
le choc après l'annoncé de la mort de
l'ex-premier ministre shinzo abe tué par
balle lors d'un discours politiques
publiques dans l'ouest du pays nous
allons retrouver quelqu'un qui connaît
bien ce pays qui y vit benoit richard
temps et qui enseigne d'ailleurs à
l'université tempo à tokyo c'est
absolument renversant de voir ces images
là on ira dans les détails plus tard
mais pouvez-vous juste dur situer dans
un contexte culturel japonais un
assassinat de politiciens avec une arme
à feu même ses élèves fabrication
artisanale c'est du jamais vu cela à peu
près
absolument c'est un événement qui est
excessivement chacun pour toutes sortes
de raisons d'abord parce que chez nous
au rabais était un géant de la politique
le politicien qui a eu le plus
d'influencé sur le rôle du japon devant
là depuis l'après guerre
c'est également un choc immense parce
que comme l'a mentionné la violence
politique qui à peu près inexistante ici
c'est un pays qui est extrêmement
sécuritaire le taux de possession
d'armes à feu est quasi nulle et en fait
le taux de meurtres en fait est le plus
bas parmi tous les pays développés du
monde alors si on met tous ces éléments
ensemble ça fait que l'événement où
cette tragédie d'aujourd'hui est
absolument est impensable en fait alors
c'est un choc pour toute la classe
politique en fait tout le japon les
directions ce fut de toutes parts
aujourd'hui ici bon là c'est de trouver
des motifs 1 puis les policiers vont
faire leur travail et cetera mais vous
avez dit que c'était un g12 la police il
vient d'une famille deux géants de toute
façon on croit comprendre c'est
pratiquement pas de père en fils qu'on
se donne d'aider des postes politiques
au japon entre dans cette famille
l'heure d'après ce que je peux lire
il y est en effet une tendance chez
plusieurs politiciens japonais d'avoir
de grandes familles politiques sont
évidemment pas le seul pays où on voit
ça mais en effet shinzo abe vient d'une
grande famille politique plutôt
conservatrice par exemple son grand père
était l'un des premiers premier ministre
de l'après guerre et a eu même un très
grand rôle à jouer dur et avant la
guerre dans la colonisation et l'évasion
de la chine par exemple donc c'était
bien une longue famille politique avec
une longue histoire politique et donc
c'est vraiment comme le mentionnait non
seulement lui un géant de la politique
mais sa femme est en soi a eu son
empreinte sur toute l'histoire du japon
depuis le depuis l'avant-guerre en fait
il n'y a pas eu peur de remuer les
traditions par contre en étant plus dur
avec la corée du nord en s'approchant
même de trope dans les dernières années
ça aussi il y avait pas une réforme
aussi
des régimes de retraite là pour les
aînés sont aussi savez ça a touché tout
le monde
ouais voilà c'est pour ça que je dis que
c'est un géant de la politique il a
effectué il affecte une transformation
du pays que cooke un autre premier
ministre avant lui avaient réussi à
faire je dirais que son héritage se fera
davantage sentir sur la politique
étrangère du japon il a fait du japon un
acteur beaucoup plus important sur le
plan de la sécurité sur le plan de la
défense il a renforcé le rôle des forces
armées qui sont en fait officiellement
des forces d'autodéfense le japon
maintenant est un acteur non seulement
dans la région mais pas ailleurs dans le
monde également on le voit depuis le
début de l'invasion russe est un acteur
qui compte beaucoup plus qu'avant et
même si chez nous au rabais n'est plus
près le ministre depuis maintenant un an
et demi son héritage se fait sentir et
va se faire sentir pendant un quart de
très longues années bon peut-être une
dernière note aussi est-ce que c'est
comme chez nous quand un politicien se
déplacent ici on pense à toi dow a
d'autres à des anciens premiers sont
toujours accompagnés d'un service de
sécurité et c est ce qu est ce que ça
donne mais parce que vous avez dit c'est
tellement pas dangereux le japon est ce
que ça existe quand même des services
pour recadrer protéger les policiers
il y a évidemment des services mais il
est très sévère marca blanc fait à quel
point la sécurité est plutôt je dirais
plus lax que chez nous et c'est tout
simplement que le mentionnait que la
politique ou que la société en fait en
est une qui est très sécuritaire je
donne un exemple extraordinaire la
semaine dernière le système à un rallye
pour un politicien à yokohama qui est
juste à côté de tokyo c'est un rallye
pour taro kono qui est un une immense
politiciens au japon et il se promenait
allègrement parmi la foule il serrait
les mains et je voyais à peu près pas de
personnes autour de lui qui semblait qui
semble s'occuper de la sécurité il y
avait des gens qui l'entouraient mais
rien comme on pouvait voir chez nous et
donc ça illustre de façon assez
probantes le fait que je que le fait
qu'on soit dans une société qui où ce
genre de violence là est tout à fait
exceptionnel on souhaite aux japonais
que ça changera pas ça parce que c'est
très beau c'est très pratique autant
pour le policier que pour les lecteurs
de pouvoir avoir accès comme ça à ses
représentants encore une fois merci
beaucoup ça va je pense avoir une grosse
soirée pour vous l'auriez seulement quoi
les 19 37 chez vous alors effectivement
sur faire l'objet de bien des
discussions et des de deuil sans doute
merci absolument merci bonne journée
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne i see her dit